[Music]
who has seen an advertisement that has
convinced you that your microphone is
listening to your conversations all of
your interactions your credit card
swipes web searches locations likes
they're all collected in real time into
a trillion dollar a year industry the
real game changer was Cambridge only to
go they'd work for the Trump campaign
and for the brexit campaign they started
using information warfare Cambridge
analytic are claimed to have 5000 data
points on every American voter I started
tracking down all these Cambridge
analytical ex-employees someone else
that you should be calling the committee
is Brittany Kaiser Brittany Kaiser
once a key player inside Cambridge
analytic casting herself as a
whistleblower the reason why Google and
powerful companies in the world is
because last year data surpassed soil in
value data is the most valuable asset on
earth
we targeted those whose minds will
thought we can change until they saw the
world the way we wanted them to I do
know that their targeting tool was
considered a weapon there is a
possibility that the American public had
been experimented on this is becoming a
criminal matter when people see the
extent of the surveillance I think
they're going to be shocked and I still
here for your life
yeah the powerful people that are
involved but I can't keep quiet it's
because if it make perfect people know
the death rights should be considered
just fundamental rights this is about
the integrity of our democracy these
platforms which were created to connect
us have now been recognized it's
impossible to know what is what
because nothing is what it seems
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]